so there's a look at chi-chi gonzalez
he's the surprise starter for the
rockies in this game john gray was
scratched forearm tightness so chi-chi
gonzalez comes out of the bullpen jeff
to start game one for the rockies yeah
he's a guy that has been struggling he's
made 16 starts this year
over a six era with eddie rosario
leading it off ozzy gets another night
off but it'll be interesting to see how
eddie fares in the lead-off role he'll
swing at the next pitch tap it towards
first krohn's got it he leads gonzalez
to the bag for a quick first down jorge
soler the braves right fielder solaire's
done a great job in the number two spot
getting on base and setting the table
solaire hits one hard out to right
center field back there at the wall one
nothing atlanta stroll their power the
opposite way over the right center field
wall and the braves have just bounded
their first of what they hope to be many
home runs in this four game series in
denver freddie freeman now pitch is hit
pretty well to center field but this
will stay in the yard
sam hilliard puts it away and
chi-chi comes back after the home run to
get the dangerous freeman for the second
out austin riley braves third baseman
having a terrific season and he takes
ball four good patience he'll hand the
baton to dansby swanson and another
brave who has loved hitting at coors
field 1-0 is sent towards right field
charlie blackman on the run near the
line makes the catch
and the damage is minimal here come the
hot-hitting colorado rockies to face
tuki toussaint who's been terrific for
the braves on the road this season
connor joe he'll lead things off that's
on the ground dansby swanson long throw
and what a play
dansby swanson has had an incredible
year defensively he saves a leadoff hit
with a great stab and a perfect peg that
brings brendan rodgers up to the plate
he bounces it by
a diving
shortstop swanson it's a one out single
one out single that brings charlie
blackman up to the plate grounded right
to freddie he's got into the hot shot to
dansby for one back to first base double
play
that is as sharp as it comes
3-6-3
and the rockies get their second base
hit a one-out runner here in the second
one on one out that brings ryan mcmahon
up to the plate 1-1 comebacker taken by
dansby takes the bag for one steps on it
fires to first double play
and the braves have turned over two
double plays in this ball game that is
6'3 twin killer shut down krone mcmahon
and the rockies all together
down to third base rosario over to
second base solaire one down for austin
riley see if he can rake in the rbis
swing and a rocket headed for the gap
that's gonna get down in score two
austin reilly makes it free to nothing
can't spell mvp without r-i-l-e-y
three runs in this ball no you're right
and that's why took you'll have to keep
going and he bunts it out to the pitcher
toussaint who throws to second and the
ball is low and swanson cannot field it
cleanly dookie had him dead to right all
he needed was a good throw made a
horrible throw to dansby so the rockies
catch a break see if they could take
advantage two on one out in the top with
the order connor joe coming up it's bang
to the left side that'll get through for
a base hit diaz scores it's now a 3-1
ball game versus that error that has got
to be driving tukey mad right about now
now the bases are loaded with one down
so let's see what tuki has in store for
charlie blackmon the rockies with nine
grand slams this year charlie owns three
in his career this is swung on and hit
high and deep to right field that is
over and out of here
grand slam charlie blackman and the
rockies take the lead five to three
things just getting worse and worse
after that error by dookie back to back
two out walks given up by chi-chi
gonzalez and here comes bud black
and that is all for chi-chi
he's gonna go to his bullpen bring out
almonte the right-hander well they will
summon him to face jorge solaire 1-1
pitch this is hit in the air right field
blackman coming in a few steps
underneath it reaches up and makes the
catch and almonte does the job he
strands a pair the braves with the tying
runs aboard and nobody out here in the
fifth inning dansby swanson
dansby swanson with a sacrifice fly and
the braves are within one it's five to
four here's adam duvall you can see
these brakes hitters they're in launch
mode right now swing
[Applause]
wow on to the concourse level braves on
top six to five
477
feet and just like that the braves got
the lead back charlie blackman steals
the base and colorado knowing it's home
field with the coors field hit a
possibility he's now in scoring position
with two outs
got him looking
story flips his bat in the air and
catches it
he got caught
looking at a fastball right there big
strikeout for webb ray's bullpen has
been excellent tonight partner they have
fired three scoreless innings next man
out of the shoot for brian schnitker is
richard rodriguez connor joe the final
hope for colorado in the seventh to deep
center field spreading magnum all he's
at the warning track at the wall he
leaps and adam has got it he just robbed
joe
of perhaps a home run and maybe extra
bases if nothing else
six five
braves tying run on go ahead run at the
plate with the national league player of
the month cj krohn
liner out to 8-8 he's got it on the
short hop takes him to the bag steps on
second and luke jackson delivers the
braves into the ninth inning with a
one-run lead braves lead by a run jack
peterson will grab a bat and come on to
try to give atlanta some insurance
[Applause]
how fancy was that
nifty pickup by trevor story to throw
out peterson who couldn't believe it
because he hit that ball hard so how
about a 30-30 night for atlanta did
paul's hit his 30th homer will smith is
going for his 30th save
ryan mcmahon left on the left ryan takes
it the opposite way beats the shift
tying run on to start the bottom of the
ninth winning run comes to the plate and
elias diaz one two pitch
got him swinging strike three tip that
fast ball into steven votes mitt one
down here in the ninth sam hilliard was
scheduled colorado goes back to its
bench and this is garrett hampson
let's see if he'd oblige with a double
play ball ground ball race to the back
there's one on to first they got him and
the braves win the game
asking you'll receive it is a 30-30
night for the braves a huge win for the
braves to start this series in denver
you